hey guys what's up this is andrew for
trading sensors.com
so in this video i want to make a quick
update on the s p 500
and on the news that happened this week
let's get into it
[Music]
all right so first the news what did we
have this week
um so on monday we had some better than
expected
gdp uh like quarterly gbp in japan
all right some chinese news
in deflation all right for the the the
earth from the for the month of november
which makes sense because
uh there was some slowing in the
activity so
this was uh expected they had like a
zero percent as a forecast
in the united states the inflation is at
one point six percent
which is as expected as last month and
which is good
close to the target of two percent right
so this is a good
sign for me and then we had some better
than expected michigan consumer
index which is basically showing you how
much people are confident
in the united states economy and in the
stock market
so this indicator is actually very
helpful
to understand uh the sentiment of the
market
then let's have a look at the market
what did happen this week all right so
very quickly this is my one two three
four five of illiot information that i
try
to draw to see if the move up that we
had since march is finished or not
uh to me it's not finished yet then if i
go to the four hours time frame
the four hours time frame is a very good
one to be used for technical analysis
because you have the flows of long-term
investors
like institutional clients or hedge
funds as well as
short-term investors like algorithm that
use about the four hours time frame to
give some signals
uh so i like this time frame there is a
lot of uh
good signals to be used so here uh
as i said last week's last week was like
the 8th of december
it was like we had a closing price of
one here and i was saying
be careful guys maybe there's going to
be some uh selling
pressure coming this week and everything
that is above 3700
i'm a seller of it i said that and what
did i do
i was a seller above 3 700 and i made
some money
uh it was uh kind of expected guys
that we had some um profits taking
at this level and this is what happened
this week uh then we broke
uh the support level of my witch pattern
that was here
uh so here for those who follow me on
instagram i was saying
uh by the deep guys a nice level to take
some profit if you were a seller
that's what i did i was uh i i stopped
my position here
and and then you could as well take this
move down
if you were playing uh the the break of
the
of the support level of the watch
pattern all right 1.3
it's nice moves guys for intraday
traders you capture one percent with
some leverage you make some money and
here it was a bit messy all right if
your stop loss
was tight you would have been stopped
probably but whatever
this was a nice um situation
to make some money now what do i see i
still have a watch pattern guys it's
you know it's same thing actually
nothing has changed we're just
drifting a bit lower but i expect some
rebound
around the 36 30 area i think we're
going to reach this
uh around tuesday monday is going to be
bearish guys things are not going well
in the discussion about the stimulus
package
the republicans and the democrats can't
agree on how to give this money to whom
give it
and it's like becoming a bit political
you know uh
so i doubt there's gonna be some good
news coming during the weekend for the
vaccines
everything is already you know sad and
good so we can only have bad news
so i think the the kind of downward
movement
that started uh on wednesday
is gonna be still at play uh
at the beginning of the week and then i
think we're gonna have a rebound around
36
25 36 30. all right guys this is a level
to buy with a tight stop plus same thing
all right you buy 37
36 30 but you can use the stop-loss at
36 10 something like this and capture
uh this move for example see so two
three percent right it's a very nice
risk reward guys
this is to me what is happening very
quickly
uh i give you again my view how i think
things are going to play out
before january so i think we have an
ending diagonal here one two three four
five
so this is the kind of formation that we
see at the end
of some moves you know ralph is an idiot
has
already uh analyzed you know a lot of
data
and he is telling us that uh ending
diagonals are usually predicting some
bigger correction
and this is an ending diagonal guys for
those who don't know what it is
please click on the link in the
description of the video and you're
going to receive a free video where i
explained everything
about illiad and how to use it so this
is an ending diagonal
and i think that it has one more move to
come
all right so it could have been like
this but this
is not working because uh the third wave
would be the shortest which is not
allowed guys
so i know this is not at play at the
moment
and i think we have something like this
so i expect two
more a bit bullish weeks to come unless
we break 36 30
unless we have some bad news and then
once we reach 36.50
my target then guys stay close to shore
because it's gonna be the time of the
correction of this
big big move up all right so don't worry
i'm gonna make a lot of updates uh
before this happens
and i hope this video was helpful and
that you enjoyed it and if you did
please click on the like button and the
subscribe button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys